[Musique]
l'importance de l'enjeu nous avons
transformé le téléjournal pour vous
proposer un débat d'une heure entre les
deux principaux candidats à la mairie
montréal valérie plantes bonsoir bonsoir
denis coderre bonsoir merci d'être là
vous allez ce soir dans une formule la
plus souple possible
débattre de cinq thèmes logement
mobilité
sécurité économie services aux citoyens
et environnement chacun aura un temps de
parole équitable qui apparaîtra
d'ailleurs régulièrement à l'écran vous
verrez mesdames et messieurs donc où
sont rendus les deux candidats
si vous parlez en même temps ce sont les
citoyens qui vont perdre je vous le
rappelle ray alors bon débat premier
thème incontournable le logement
la question c'est à savoir si les taxes
foncières vont augmenter cet axe bien
avec est toujours affaire dont c'est la
crise du logement les gens autour de
nous arracher leur jus c'est un peu de
bon sens comme un test clé logement
augmentent ici c'est abordable c'est
certain que j'aurai à montréal haut ce
que tout le monde s'arrache pour les
logements à prix modiques eu beaucoup de
monde car nombre de zones non de
logement social cruellement depuis
plusieurs années tout le monde pour me
dire jamais mais c'est vous pourriez
rien qui a été construit au niveau des
maisons et si c'est pas achetable à
montréal qu'on peut pas vraiment être
objective el-assad berthou de la hausse
des prix on va devoir sortie dé lille
probable les prix sont pas accessibles
alors pour acheter ce souk et se sert et
difficile
ça a été le sujet de préoccupation
numéro un quand je me suis promené dans
les rues de montréal pour faire des
rencontres avec les citoyens la question
est fort simple comment fait-on pour
garder les familles à montréal et
accroître l'offre de logement je vous
donne un seul chiffre et c'est un record
depuis 20 ans il ya trente cinq mille
neuf cents personnes qui ont quitté
l'île de montréal au profit des des
banlieues première deuxième troisième
couronne alors comment on fait pour
garder les gens sur l'île monsieur
coderre vous avez 45 secondes mais dans
un premier temps c'est clair que la
notion de densité est essentiel parce
qu'on peut parler évidemment quand on
parle de logement social c'est une chose
à part on a besoin ya des problèmes
spécifiques à ça mais si on veut avoir
une incidence sur les prix au niveau de
l'habitation pour l'accès à la propriété
et tout ce qui est abordable on a besoin
de doper l'offre là pour ce faire on a
besoin d'une plus grande densité alors
intervient de cette façon là moi je
pense qu'il faut être beaucoup plus
inclusive dans le processus travailler
aussi avec les développeurs tous les to
letuppe l'institutionnel tous ceux et
celles qui ont un rôle à jouer au niveau
de l'habitation pour qu'on puisse
travailler ensemble on veut tous de la
mixité sociale moi je suis en désaccord
avec que le le fameux règlement 20 20 20
parce que je pense que saclay l'exode
mais on pourrait en parler pendant le
débat mais on a besoin d'une nouvelle
stratégie d'habitation qui sera beaucoup
plus pragmatique comment on fait pour
garder les gens montréal valérie plan de
45 secondes oui merci alors oui
effectivement quand on regarde des
villes comme toronto vancouver qui ont
perdu la bataille c'est parce qu'il y
avait pas de réglementation ils ont
laissé le marché
ils l'ont laissé faire ça pas fonctionné
alors pour nous comme administration
pilote renault prochain mandat on veut
continuer de trouver des solutions qui
sont concrètes ça passe par soixante
mille logements abordables sur dix ans
et la façon de le faire c'est d'acheter
les terrains pour garder un levier pour
que ça reste abordable sur 40 ans parce
qu'en ce moment ce qui se passe c'est
que des gens qui prennent des logements
abordables et qui les transforment ils
font des flips et sa soeur du marché ou
si le règlement sur le 20/20 nous assure
que tout le monde dont les promoteurs
immobiliers sont autour de la table pour
avoir 20% de logement social et
abordable et familiale 20 % pour chaque
et c'est comme ça qu'on veut conserver
la mixte et économiques culturels et
sociale de la ville de montréal merci
madame lambert justement il ya deux
visions qui s'affrontent est-ce qu'on
doit et finalement c'est la question
forcer les promoteurs à construire du
logement abordable ce coderre vous
lancer le débat ouvert est-ce que c'est
pas utopique de croire que ça va pousser
tout faire mais ce qui est utopique
c'est penser que ans on va donner des
chiffres qu'il faut se donner les moyens
de la réalité de les réaliser alors si
on veut travailler ton on a quatre ans
qu'on regarde par rapport aux chiffres
ce qu'on a livré comme marchandise en
moi ce que je dis c'est que oui on a
besoin de réglementation on n'a pas
besoin de règlement qui va restreindre
davantage est actuellement point de vue
de même à radio canada il y avait des
reportages là dessus avec le 20/20 les
gens s'en vont alors est ce qu'on a
besoin de willems on peut acheter des on
peut acheter des terrains on a
d'ailleurs avec le statut de métropole
la capitale sans forcer les premiers
aspen question de forcer c'est une
question de travailler en équipe et
s'assurer que sept accusés ont travaillé
en équipe ça c'est que tu as fait
faisant parce que quand on pense au
projet molson où est ce qu il yal
règlement d'inclusion en fait il n'était
même pas encore en place que molson
montrent un monteur voyons montagny et
le groupe sélection des gros promoteurs
ont dit 'nous on embarque il y croit
alors pour moi cette notion qu'elle ait
tous les promoteurs immobiliers ne
veulent pas de cette réglementation je
n'y crois pas et il faut voir également
que les villes comme gatineau qui
regarde notre règlement petit et je
pense et cette profondeur qu'on fasse
finalement si vous me permettez dans les
cinquante mille logements que vous
pourrez vous promettez monsieur coderre
à cause qu'il y aucun règlement pour
gérer l'offre de logements abordables et
social les deux tiers ne seront pas
accessibles à la classe moyenne c'est
juste les plus riches qui vont pouvoir
les acheter situé dans le centre-ville
et ça pour moi ce n'est pas ma
définition de la mixtape pour moi je ne
sais pas exactement quand on parle de
cinquante mille à d'habitation en 4 1
parce qu'il faut livrer la marchandise
on peut donner des chiffres mais quand
on regarde ceux qui habitent le solo de
problème alors le 5 ans mais le volcan
katla mbour 10 mille de logements
sociaux on va voir on va voir une
réglementation souple qui va nous
permettre de travailler mais quand vous
dites par exemple au niveau de molson il
ya un problème parce que les logements
sociaux sont trop élevés à cause de
votre définition de la densité donc il
faut qu'on se donne des outils plus les
moyens qu'ils adaptent je peux en parler
mais la majeure partie des développeurs
sont contraints
par les grands ainsi mais moi j'en sois
vous entendre parler concrètement vous
avez des dix mille logements sociaux
mais je passais défendent de québec vous
ne parlez pas du logement abordable
comment recruter un logement abordable
si aucune réglementation dans le
centre-ville et si vous me permettez à
ce niveau-là l'abordabilité surtout
celles qui pérenne celle qui est pérenne
parce que ce qu'on veut éviter la c'est
que nos enfants et nos petits-enfants
puissent plus jamais habité morel et là
dessus je pense que vous avez un double
discours on va pas se le cacher votre
table dans la mairie fait d'événements
d'anvers dont you call of duty message
que ça envoie aux citoyens qui aux
familles qui veulent rester agréable et
disco l'abordabilité l'incidence sur les
prix ont un lien direct avec la densité
quand vous avez plus d'offres les prix
baissent alors on n'est pas là pour
gérer les prix mais si on veut
travailler un thème d'abordable il faut
les livrer cette marchandise l'a donc au
lieu de donner des chiffres on l'a dit
pendant qu'à dix ans puis pérennité
pendant 40 ans on a besoin de choses
immédiatement les gens qui nous gagnons
besoin de réalisation immédiate et c'est
pour ça qu'on a bien donné ce roi si je
pouvais définir selon moi notre vision
chacun c'est pour moi c'est un droit
fondamental habitation puis pour
monsieur coderre c'est un bien de
consommation c'est pas je suis un bien
de consommation parce que vous avez vous
même ne nous ment et moi main on a une
propriété il ya un élément aussi de
stabilité économique avec soi puis il
peut y avoir éventuellement un fonds de
pornichet ce dont il faut faire
attention mais on a besoin de livrer la
marchandise les gens qui posent des
questions lors ce qu'ils veulent c'est
des réponses qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
rapidement très bien le les gens aussi
voit l'inflation
tout coûte plus cher il drones vu tous
les sens la nourriture est là les taxes
il ya méfiant sur les taxes les gens
d'ici l'inflation reste 4,4 d'un record
18 ans pendant quelques années en tout
cas quelques mois qu'est ce que vous
faites avec les taxes madame plan qui
donne la parole ensuite débat ouvert qui
se poursuit qu'est ce que vous faites en
fait ce qu'on veut c'est garder les
taxes à l'inflation pendant tout le
mandat est ce qu'on s'est engagé à faire
parce que en sortie de crise économique
il ya beaucoup plus de fluctuation mais
dans la première année on veut s'assurer
de rester aux 2%
ce que le message que j'envoie
aujourd'hui c'est que c'est l'année
d'après là encore une inflation est à
4.5 on n'ira jamais là l'idée c'est de
ne porte
pour le
nous ce qu'on a dit depuis le début je
suis content que madame plantes j'ai ça
au début c'était que l'inflation près
vous avez dû pour ça maintenant c'est
votre mode d'administration qui avaient
dit qu'ils augmenteraient poids des
taxes qui d augmenter au début de votre
premier mandat moi je pense que nous en
moyenne on est un point 8 % je pense que
la première étape c'est de s'assurer que
l'on puisse se voir comment les dépenses
en sont faites mais on veut que ce soit
1 % la première année ça c'est une
petite vite là parce que les gens nous
ont tellement écrit au sujet du
programme de remboursement partiel de la
taxe de bienvenue le problème c'est que
le seuil d'admissibilité son âme là est
tellement aborde dans la vraie vie vous
vouliez des vingt mille personnes y en a
six mille juifs ont fait quoi avec ce
week-end et je dois dire je suis très
fier parce que quand tu arrivé en poste
le plafond à la base est allé à 250
milles sous l'administration ne se
connaît on le monte entre 450 et jusqu'à
650 me dans les quartiers centraux mais
clairement on voit que le besoin est là
alors
réalité là c'est qu'il va falloir qu'on
se dise
est-ce qu'on a là la question la taxe de
bienvenue c'est quelque chose d'un peu
un dessin puis pour se faire si on
dépend notre budget dépend 76 % taxe
foncière donc il est temps qu'on
réévalue ça qu'on dit vérifient notre
source de revenus et puis qu'on arrête
de tergiverser sur speed peu importe
l'administration là je pense qu'il faut
repenser cette question de taxes de
permutations passera pas de bon sens il
ya des gens qui n'ont pas de logement le
problème de l'itinérance à montréal
écoutez ceci
mais c'est surtout les itinérants
leur trouver
leur trouver des moyens qu'on puisse
nous trouver des moyens pour qu'on
puisse les aider ça prend des gens qui
savent comment remplir la paperasse
ouais parce que seulement le plus
cerveau pour le faire ça prendrait
lavoir public avec des douches publiques
juste pour faire de notre lavage pour
les toilettes après 10 heures c'est
vraiment compliqué c'est on pense pas
seul mais c'est vraiment c'est un
problème souvent un problème
cette dame là c'est comment elle elle
vous dit elle est dans la rue comment
faciliter ma vie oui les grands
principes on veut tous les enlever de la
rue mais des lavoirs publics des lieux
ouverts madame plantes qu'est-ce qu'on
fait définitivement pendant la coiffeuse
on a vu que la précarité étaient
exacerbées en or un certain qu'on les
refuges parle qu'il ya eu à le doubler
le nombre de personnes en situation
d'itinérance donc clairement oui faut
mettre plus de refuge ou est-ce que des
services comme des douches des lavoirs
mais honnêtement il faut aussi qu'on
sorte de cette logique été hiver parce
que c'est comme ça que ça fonctionne
présentement le gouvernement du québec
est en charge de l'itinérance au sens
très large et le nous ce qu'on demande
c'est un plan sur cinq ans pour arrêter
de faire des délits d' urgence l'hiver
et l'été on leur dit bon on va partir
dans la nature ça ne fonctionne plus et
donc on veut pouvoir des robes de
l'argent de québec que vous dites c'est
normal parce que si on a on est
tributaire on s'occupe on est mandataire
de l'itinérance à montréal mais ça pond
sous le jupon si je peux dire de la
femme je connais ce dossier là me touche
profondément et je pense pas que ça soit
juste la faute à québec il faut qu'on se
prenne en main sous la responsabilité de
tous on doit investir on doit s'investir
et la métropole doit voir personne de
laissés pour compte et en ce sens nous
avions omis dès le premier mandat une
politique en ce sens je sens que du côté
de l'administration actuelle on en
apprend on a un peu pas mal laisser
tomber donc c'est pas juste une question
de refuser une question de transition on
doit mettre de l'avant une nouvelle
stratégie avec les communautaires vous
savez que l'itinérance a plusieurs
visages de la réalité des femmes de
l'arrêté autochtone gardait milton park
est un fléau donc il faut que des gestes
posés très clairement nous on a proposé
plus de 60 millions $ en ce sens là et
travailler en collaboration avec les
autres gouvernements mais la ville a une
responsabilité qu'on n'assume pas
présent ok vous me permettez que pendant
la cobi dont on a pu voir à quel point
la ville quand elle dit qu'elle ne
laisse personne derrière ces personnes
et tous les itinérants ont été pris en
charge sans entente québec et parce
qu'on travaille en équipe avec les
intervenants communautaires très bien
deuxième thème
ça c'est pas difficile d'avoir des
commentaires des montréalais là dessus
c'est la mobilité ouais
[Musique]
on va peut-être l'espace pour le vélo
est un sport plus sécuritaire les vélos
france est important les routes sont
rendus si cela conduit à cause des
pistes cyclables trop de pistes
cyclables un peu d'autres pistes
cyclables
il ya rien de ma vie que les gens sur
quelques son vélo piste cyclabe ça
arrange beaucoup de monde mais ça
dérange beaucoup les personnes en
voiture
transpole pas mal déficiente
transparence et en rire avoir un
meilleur service de transport en commun
akale métro dans l'est
parce que des gros problèmes de
circulation
morel une vie qui est en permanence en
chantier les travaux la coordination des
travaux trafic tellement travaillé dur
au clair qu stationner et pompiers la
police et les livres harry peuvent pas
circuler passer dans un circuit en ville
on dirait que c'est fait exprès pour que
ça marche pour
question et vous aurez 45 secondes pour
y répondre est ce que montréal est
condamné à être bloquée madame plantes
45,5 la réponse est non mais ça passe
définitivement par une plus grande offre
de transport collectif c'est vraiment ça
la clé et c'est pourquoi depuis quatre
ans notre équipe a tellement mis
d'énergie que ce soit pour la ligne rose
que ce soit pour leur m2 de l'ess que ce
soit pour l'un srb pie-ix la ligne bleue
les 300 autobus parce que sa farce par
plus de mobilité nécessairement quand on
enlève des gens sur la route quand on
est capable quand ils se retrouvent un
transport collectif ça laisse plus de
place également pour les personnes qui
ont besoin se déplacer en voiture
absolument pour différentes raisons mais
aussi pour tout ce qui touche la
logistique parce que la ville de
montréal est un pôle logistique très
important alors moi je mise comme en
2007 sur la mobilité le transport
collectif et le transport actif qui est
complémentaire évidemment on va en
reparler bien sûr du transport collectif
la stm en trop chez coderre vaut 45 de
la mobilité story so c'est clair donc ce
qu'on voit en plus c'est qu'on doive
penser aux piétons les voitures lors
fort et aidé et anti voiture faut
arrêter de porc travailler dans un
contexte de cohabitation la voiture et
là on peut la transformer on peut
travailler sur l'autopartage davantage
mais il ya des gens qui ont besoin de
leur voiture quand ils vont emmener
leurs enfants à l'école quand ils vont
chercher des des commandes quelconque
que des réalités de sécurité également
on a besoin d'une vraie cohabitation et
malheureusement c'est pas le cas présent
si le des gens qui sont frustrés c'est
aussi à cause de ce sommet on empêche
pas qu on doit avoir une meilleure offre
dont nous parlait du rem leur m2 est
essentiel dans l'est de montréal on doit
repenser aussi à la stm de façon dont
dans certains voyaient venir
certainement pour moi on a besoin de
ramener cette cohabitation c'est pour un
contrôle les gens nous ont beaucoup dit
qu'on allait les rencontrer l'état des
routes ou si ça me plaît beaucoup j'aime
bien sûr ma rue pourquoi les budgets
puissant vous a des trous chief manager
messieurs mais les budgets vous aviez
comment commencer à monter plante deux
premières années
puis 20 et 21 le budget d'entretien des
routes a fondu est-ce que débat ouvert
qui commençait ce qu' il n'y a pas un
problème parce qu'on devrait et on
n'aurait pas dû mettre les bouchées
doubles oui tout à fait pu en fait faut
pas oublier que dans la vallée deux
dernières années pendant la cua vide
pendant presque je voudrais un bon 8
mois toutes les opérations a été
vraiment vraiment diminué donc pour nous
de s'occuper des repas ce code non
seulement c'est bon pour tout le monde
s'occupait des routes là on c'est bon
pour les piétons c'est bon plaisir clé
c'est bon les automobilistes donc aucune
raison de ne pas investir massivement et
quand on regarde notre plan triennal
d'investissement la part qui est donné
vie dans le budget de fonctionnement la
part qui est prévu pour la réparation et
de la réparation des routes pardon est
importante alors on remet pas en
question vous sentez le sens parce que
quand on a mis en place justement le
programme de réparation des routes lior
premièrement toute la question le on
voit l'urgence les codes rouge puis on
voulait avoir à remplir les nids de
poule et tout ça est votre parti est un
con maintenant on a c'est une réalité de
la vie on aux treize mille kilomètres de
routes des groupies d'accueil gic puis
ça coûte deux points 1 milliard par
année juste pour la mise à niveau donc
il faut s'assurer que aussi qu'on ait
des produits adéquats pour cela vous
vous souvenez que dans notre mandat
c'est après aussi la commission
charbonneau y avait une incidence des
puits il y avait une réalité on avait
avec l'inspecteur général on aurait de
l'est la situation de la corruption et
de la collusion absolue une incidence de
30% de man au niveau des prix je
comprends que les prix sont très élevés
aussi maintenant mais on a besoin de
réparer des ruines assureront la cdu ne
permet tait parce qu'une nuance affaire
c'est que l'ordre quand vous étiez maire
vous faisait des travaux et vous fermiez
ça reste à l'identique ses skippers avec
5 4e saint denis et donc nous ce qu'on a
testé en arrivant comme administration
c'est que quand on fait des rénovations
quand on refait une rue on a refait pas
à l'identique on réfléchit l'expert de
la boit et on regarde quels sont les
besoins des citoyens qui habitent dans
le quartier qui passe à travers le
quartier et moi je constate c'est la
meilleure façon d'utiliser l'argent et
je pense que le rêve saint denis on en
est le meilleur exemple ça avait été
refait à l'identique
on ne décide d'y installer une piste
clame un million de passages qui a été
célébrée dimanche et 30 nouveaux
commerces qui se sont installés sur
saint denis alors qu'il était mais vous
vous dites comme montréal et qui
aimerait que le russe soit en meilleur
état est-ce que ça ça en viennent à
penser que c'est pas tous les arts tél
on va revenir sur la question de
s'indigner c'est 400 m à l'époque parce
que les tuyaux coup les tuyaux couler de
partout puis plus on est longtemps sur
un chantier plus les commerces ferment
donc il faut travailler là dessus dans
l'ensemble et en plus vous avez coupé
les subventions au niveau des
infrastructures locales et si une
réalité aussi pour la qualité de vie
pour les artères locale donc on a besoin
de réparer des rues il ya des choses
qu'on doit faire on doit pas tout
repenser tout le temps des rues et des
artères on y repense pendant neuf ans
nous aussi mais à un moment donné il
faut être concret il faut s'assurer que
parce que
oui on répare les rues et on travaille
les donneurs d'ouvragé pour s'assurer
que quand la ville ou parce que 25% des
travaux c'est la ville de montréal soit
5,15 pour ça ce sont d'autres donneurs
d'ouvragé compagnies de
télécommunications d'énergie des
propriétaires privés alors nous on aide
à coordonner parce que on ne veut pas
qu'il ya un trou qu'ils se fassent par
la ville s'est refermée qu'hydro québec
c'est un plateau j'ai une question pour
vous grâce j'ai une question pour vous
deux qui pourrait aider la mobilité et
l'environnement et la qualité de vie des
montréalais
c'est les gros camions qui font de la
livraison dans les quartiers à aurillac
comment ça se fait que c'est encore
permis alors si longtemps que ça parlait
on est mis en place le projet colibri
qui viendra encore mais oui mais je
d'accord mais on a mis en place un
projet pilote pour amener du transport
électrique des plus petits véhicules ou
même des vélos cargo dans le
centre-ville entre autres où il ya des
camions qui arrivent un centre de
transbordement qui est à l'ancienne gare
voyageurs et à partir de là le dernier
kilomètre ce fait on transporte beaucoup
plus petit beaucoup plus doux plus
sécuritaire et c'est ça qu'il faut faire
pour préserver la sécurité de nos
milieux dits oui beaucoup dans les
martyrs et camions la réalité c'est
qu'on se parle points si on doit on
devrait faire ce sommet du camion qu'on
veut faire pour avoir une stratégie de
l'ivresse ça se fait dans d'autres
grandes villes du monde si on dit par
exemple 9 heures puis 11 heures le matin
là ça va être la livraison premièrement
vous allez désengorger certains secteurs
ça va être d'autant plus sécuritaire
mais il faut aussi penser que au niveau
des camions la sécurité est important de
toutes les jaquettes et puis comme on a
fait dans le sound propre matériel
roulant montréal maintenant c'est bien
comme ce qu'adam et les gens veulent des
solutions maintenant des camions
électriques et des vélos cargo ça marche
c'est ça l'avenir c'est ce que toutes
les grandes du monde alors repoussé
cette idée bien jeu pour le transfert
énergétique je peux plein avec ça mais
le commerçant qui a besoin de vendre ces
choses ou bien l'épicerie que besoin de
ces fruits frais ça fait partie de la
qualité de vie oscille donc ci est
bloqué parce que les routes sont trop
restreinte si on n'est pas capable
vous avez parlez vous de des vélos des
du rêve sur saint denis ya et regarder
sa yam moins un million en 2020 de
montréalais qui ont fait du vélo c'est
une augmentation de 42% par rapport à
est-ce que la résumer - sont clairement
sous l'un est ce qu'on doit faire plus
de paix cela est ce qu'on doit faire
moins mais cela monsieur coderre a
résumé un plan bien il faut les enlever
en plus mais de façon intelligente comme
on le fait par exemple pour le rêve
saint denis le rêve des chats sont en
train de faire le rêve sur pillon
l'examen en même temps c'est des projets
qui prennent à peu près trois ans
planification qui s'assure que la
sécurité des piétons des cyclistes et au
final moi je veux dire quand on parle de
mobilité mon critère numéro un c'est la
sécurité sur saint denis il y avait eu
plus de 300 collision dont trois morts
il était engagé on a fait le rêve est
maintenant la circulation est apaisé
c'est complètement un autre milieu
depuis qu'on a eu on a fait il ya aucun
petit vélo ici moi aussi j'en fais du
vélo mais un moment donné il faut
travailler en termes de cohabitation un
des problèmes vous avez les voitures
versus les cyclistes les cyclistes
versus les piétons et un problème donc
puis quand on fait une piste cyclable
sécurisée ou non si on donne
l'impression qu'on le fait à un moment
où on a l'impression qu'on soit faire
une passe parce que pas eu de
consultation c'est un problème aux sites
dont on ne faisait pas de problème on
avait le meilleur plan vélo d'ailleurs
vélo québec en 2010 est le dixième donc
continuer pour ce continent enfin bon
votre fin de cette rencontre non mais de
façon très concrète mais on a besoin de
se retrouver le point n'est besoin d'une
meilleure cohabitation et mais on veut
réduire le nombre de voitures en
autopartage plus se faire
j'ai moins
je peux vous dire c'est que je suis
c'est vrai que ça a été difficile pour
les commerçants de la rue saint denis la
d re l'année dernière pour nous décider
dommages et les dédommager pour
certaines pertes mais vous rendez vous
compte à quel point quand on parle d'une
relance verte et inclusive la leur et
aime ça n'est un symbole hyper concret
où justement on est en train de revoir
nos aménagements nos façons de vie dans
la ville est encore une fois en ayant la
place pour tout le monde un des
commentaires que j'entends beaucoup sur
saint-denis d otto bock automobilistes
qui me disent je le sais où aller les
vélos sont là aussi ça fait mon affaire
bien sous faut changer nos comportements
mais l'idée que le jeu de piste clamé
fait de façon intelligente sur les
grands axes huit minutes 16 vous deux
les classes ne vous inquiétez pas tout
mais je le regarde monsieur monsieur
coderre madame plante une question avant
de clore ce débat la stm un déficit de
60 2 millions est-ce qu'on va être
obligé de couper des services et donc il
ya encore cinquante cinq pour cent de
l'achalandage simplement aujourd'hui le
rapport à l'enveloppé qu'est-ce qu'on
fait que les déficits monsieur près la
réalité c'est que quand on coupe un
dollar d'une place ce point dollars
d'économies à la stm parce que 70% des
de l'exploitation c'est des salaires
donc si on veut couper dans les sens
veut pas couper dans les services
premièrement ce cas la responsabilité de
la ville parce que la stm c'est un
budget de la ville donc il peut combler
ce déficit là mais si on ne veut pas
couper les services se 30% la faute
reprendre un service administratif c'est
qu'on devra obligé de couper 50% des
services administratifs de st alors
concrètement ce qu'il faut c'est le nom
de ne pas affecter le transport l'offre
de service parce que si on veut ramener
les gens dans les autobus qui est
absolument nécessaire
il faut pas que l'oeuvre soit moins
important au bord d'une heure non mais
non sinon d'ailleurs je sais pendant
l'aquavit j'avais tenu à garder les
services parce qu'on savait qu'ils
avaient plein des infirmières des gens
de première ligne qui prenait le métro
pas question d'ajouter un temps d'arrêt
voilà aucun couple
faire ce qu'il faut pouvoir faire c'est
de l'acupuncture bien sûr sur certaines
lignes de faire de l'optimisation mais
pour moi de garder laquelle
libre-service est absolument crucial si
on avait pour donner le plein service
met des services pendant la pandémie on
serait pas dans cette situation là
aujourd'hui c'est des gens des systèmes
mls est déjà attendu
que les gens ont besoin d'aller l avant
et d'avoir un salaire trois amis pour le
pour le ticket
s'apprend pas à changer en aura d'autres
bus sera pour tout ça demande six mois
d'avancé ce que vous savez madame
plantes malheureusement c'est que si on
est obligé de couper dans les services
là c'est encore plus de monde qui vont
être touchés devant moi
et je suis très fier leur avoir fait
d'avoir mis des vignettes avoir mis de
stationnement gratuit et d'avoir gardé
tous les services de la star ac pas tout
le monde loin de voitures monsieur
coderre prochain thème
la sécurité
point d'une sécurité là c'est très
important pour moi ça s'est lassé
militaire je ne sens pas habilité
avec les armes à feu beaucoup plus de
contrôle plus de sécurité qu'est ce
qu'ils vont faire dans le plan de
financement de la police c'est ce qu'on
a besoin de fructueuses de policiers
s'est rendu que c'est on n'a pas plus de
sécurité sinon mouche des ménages
plus de sécurité a dit cette dame sinon
je déménage alors ça fait les manchettes
régulièrement vous le voyez ça c'est les
incidents impliquant des armes à feu à
montréal de 41 en 2019 on est rendu à 97
puis c'est pas tout à fait du dos pierre
par exemple plus qu'hier soir exactement
monsieur coderre est ce que montréal est
encore une ville sécuritaire 45 selon
royal n'est pas sécuritaire présentement
dans le reconnaissent en elle peut le
redevenir et c'est pour cette raison
qu'aujourd'hui dans notre plan on a dit
qu'il faut non seulement augmenter les
effectifs donc le plafond étant à 4800
nous sommes à quatre mille cinq cent
vingt ans on doit on doit l'augmenter
davantage donc on va faire ça donc le
prêt de 7 novembre on va augmenter
l'effectif puis on vous demande à québec
même d'augmenter le plafond à 5109
besoin on a besoin de moderniser spvm
également qu'ils ont besoin d'outils on
dit que même dans certains éléments dans
les armes intermédiaires ils sont
désuètes qui en ont besoin mais on doit
on doit travailler aussi pour les
caméras portatives ces caméras
portatives la pointe est essentielle
mais il faut travailler avec le
communautaire et augmenter
les escouades mixant 60 merci monsieur
coderre madame plantes oui merci
beaucoup oui ça a été une année
difficile pour les montréalais et
montréalaises
on sort de là covin pendant la corvée
tout le monde était chez soi quand on a
commencé à rouvrir le crime organisé de
l'uci a pris la place puis s'est modifié
je pense que ce qui est important c'est
de pouvoir amener des solutions qui sont
très concrètes comme nous on le fait
depuis le départ depuis le début parce
que c'est un
comment dire c'est une situation qui
évolue ceci étant dit on aura la chance
d'en parler mais de là à dire que la
ville est dangereuse non de la bouche du
candidat à la mairie je trouve que c'est
mettre de côté tout le travail de celles
et ceux qui assurent notre protection
les organismes communautaires j'ai envie
de vous dire même tous nos partenaires
de l'écosystème économique tourisme au
real et autres qui font des pieds des
mains les universités qui essaie
d'amener les étudiants et le message
pour leur physique montréal est
dangereuse je trouve que c'est
irresponsable donc vous dites qu'on va
trop loin casser l'image absolument le
nombre de policiers par cent mille
habitants c'est important vu remontrer
parce qu'on a l'impression qu'il y en a
beaucoup moins c'est faux il y en a plus
à montréal 220 par cent mille habitants
à winnipeg 70 ceps toronto on a moins de
policiers par son âme il que toronto est
ce que c'est vraiment la solution de
mettre plus de policiers monsieur
coderre des bovins tout à fait c'est une
des solutions est tout savez quand on se
promène sur le terrain les gens ont
parlé gens ont même des dix pensent que
on les voit pas pourquoi parce qu' il
manque 2 153 effectifs parce que vous
avez des gens qui sont complètement à
terre qu'il y aurait une réalité aussi
au niveau des policiers là quand on
oblige des policiers dans un poste comme
le poste 21 de travailler cap
obligatoirement avec du temps
supplémentaire au bout de la ligne
dont j'étais qui en a besoin car avant
que ce soit alors oui les policiers font
toujours à chaque année quand les
départs à la retraite pouvoir pallier à
ces besoins la fin d'année en année ça
va près entre 120 et 180 cette année
nous on en a mis deux cent vingt la
prochaine année ça va être 220 également
mais vous savez ce que il manque
vraiment un élément dans ce que vous
dites monsieur connaît ici même pas dans
votre plan de ce matin c'est l'apport
également du communautaire d'ailleurs
votre plan des côtes chiffré à bord les
250 policiers vous ne l'avez pas chiffré
et moi je pense que les mots rialet
quand on voit la lumière des chefs cette
importance du roman rialet qu'est ce
qu'on va investir dans les quatre
prochaines années nous c'est 110
millions sur trois axes qui sont
chiffrées le premier c'est pour elle t'a
ya le trot trafic d'armes ensuite c'est
pour les groupes contre les groupes
criminalisés et finalement tout le
travail du communautaire ça c'est les
gens qui sont sur le terrain qu'ils
connaissent les familles qui ont une
capacité d'aller intervenir de faire des
programmes de prévention qui sont
complémentaires à la police
dix millions de plus pour les quatre
prochaines années premier ça va coûter
monsieur coderre j'avais manqué une
belle conférence de presse parce que les
augmenter les effectifs ces 120 millions
sur quatre ans les caméras portatives
c'est 30 millions sur quatre ans donc
oui puis on a parlé non seulement nous
parler du communautaire mon veut
s'investir dans le communautaire vous
avez fait même une conférence de presse
l'autre fois avec les policiers vous
mêmes pour inviter fait qu'on n'a pas de
leçons à recevoir mais on doit payer sur
le chiffrer le montant pour la
communauté à votre goût du communautaire
et les montants qu'ils voient qu'ils
vont être nécessaires il voir des
dizaines de millions qui sont rattachés
à ça mais ce qu'on a besoin parce qu'on
sait qu'à chaque dollar qu on investit
dans le communautaire on en sauve ça
alors on veut travailler ensemble mais
il faut arrêter de prendre la police
comme juste l'outil de coercition c'est
aussi et y ont aussi un rôle social à
jouer on peut tirer toutes les lettres
de l'alphabet pfa des escouades la
réalité c'est que depuis deux ans sarr
en pis et puis on a besoin de donner des
outils tant au niveau policier qu'au
niveau communautaire
des balles évidemment parce que l'année
dernière faut se rappeler que les
policiers de la ville de montréal gérer
un couvre feu c'est ça qui faisait là un
couvre-feu entre autant il fallait pas
les itinérants on devait rentrer à une
certaine heure à cause le gouvernement
du québec avait demandé donc ce sera
l'année dernière et en novembre monsieur
caron les chefs de police me dit madame
plantes on sent qu'il va y avoir une
recrudescence quand on voit sauter de
déconfinement dès le mois de décembre
mon ami est un l'escouade de lutte conte
le trafic dans le fait que pour vous ce
point important mais très cette escouade
l'heure c'est 450 âmes à partir de
janvier côté est retiré et eu 28
arrestations donc pour moi d'agir de
façon
cohérente et globale et c'est pour ça
pour moi de ne pas nommer dans votre
sortie le communautaire comme il se doit
avec démonta alors qu'ils font le
travail colossal je trouve que c'est un
acte sommes en jeu pendant ce point
d'actes manqués c'est que vous avez eu
une vocation tardive sur les questions
de sécurité maintenant vous vous en
occupez mal à vous et et voreppe isère
était là pendant quatre ans dis moi
c'est moi je peux le maire de ville de
venise de leur devenir rien à voir mais
sur le terrain les gens ont peur des
gens ont besoin d'outils les gens besoin
d'avoir plus de policiers sur le terrain
puis on doit aussi puis c'est que là
qu'on a fait le moratoire sur la
question des postes de quartier on
comprenait à l'époque mais là on doit
aussi assurer une présence à rivière des
prairies pointe au train on a besoin de
chacun d'un poste de quartier cette
présence physique et cette présence le
travail était absolument exceptionnelle
les caméras portatives si la nouvelle
panacée tout le monde est d'accord vous
aviez dit non après
projet pilote
scolaire visite dans les coins signer
sans jo premier sanjou fait ça est ce
que vraiment vous pensez que ça peut
changer la dynamique entre autres sur le
profilage racial quel est l'objectif en
fait oui ça va changer ça va changer
parce que mieux vaut laisser madame
merci
aux moyens plusieurs outils pour année
la transparence et d'imputabilité puis
pour protéger autant les citoyens mais
également les policiers donc les caméras
portatives mais aussi une politique
d'interpellations ça n'existait pas au
québec montréal a lancé ce projet là
alors pour moi c'est plusieurs outils
c'est aussi grâce à la commission de la
sécurité publique que nous avons rendu
public parce qu'avant ça se passait
derrière des portes closes on n'est
destiné qu'à transparence était
important donc il faut plusieurs outils
pour rassurer la population mais
également pour que miettes aux policiers
de bien faire leur toiture vous êtes
d'accord total la mède et d'autres
villes au canada qu'il utilise la grc
veulent avoir également celui c'est un
peu comme le principe des des caméras
dans l'est dans les taxis quand on sait
qui on est surveillé quant on sait qu'on
est capable de voir aussi l'autre côté
de la médaille sur le plan ou au niveau
même de ce qui se passe dans ton
environnement ça va avoir un impact
il ya toute la question de la pluie des
données privées la gestion des données
privées sur ces collectes mais on en a
besoin je suis content maintenant que
vous soyez d'accord on peut juste pas
d'accord avec votre projet pilote qui
était mal attachés d'ailleurs on à
l'impôt pu s'en servir
comme excuse non c'est différent de ne
pas avoir des données qu'on aurait pu se
servir en cours je pense que les caméras
portatives la première raison c'est de
pouvoir après ça nous sert un bond comme
policier ou comme citoyenne
table économie et vous allez voir ça va
être touché un thème très concret
services aux citrons
qu'est ce que la mairie pourrait faire
pour améliorer l'accessibilité à
universelle
où l'état des trottoirs aussi c'est
toujours très agréable
c'est comme mes taxes montrond
photograffiti l'édifice et beaucoup
d'édifices trouviez c'est tout mais
gainey se doit qu'on a des belles choses
qui ont en commun les entretenir la
ville soit plus agréable aussi
- fall
la propreté montréal pauvreté des rues
qui s'est pas vraiment après il ya des
déchets partout je trouve que c'est pas
une ville propre mais qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire ou
ailleurs moi je serai candidat à la
mairie chat me ferait mal d'entendre ça
on peut importe montréal qui a encore
perçu par trop de citoyens comme une
ville sale 45 secondes chacun madame
plantes et pour moi ce qui est important
ce sur quoi on doit agir c'est
définitivement on vous l'avait dit les
services aux citoyens parce que à la
base une ville ça s'occupe du
déneigement du nettoyage à l' offre
également des services eps de toutes
sortes a les permis et autres mais c'est
normal que les montréalais montréalaise
s'attendent à ce que ça se passe bien
alors autant le déneigement s'il ya des
responsables qui sont en arrondissement
et à la ville et on doit avoir une
meilleure concertation ça s'est beaucoup
améliorée depuis qu'on est équipé par
exemple les camions de gps sont des
affaires très concret mais aussi au
niveau des poubelles ce qu'on a ou de la
propreté on a rajouté des escouades il
faut continuer à le faire entre autres
aussi s'occuper des équipes pour
déneiger pour les personnes à mobilité
réduite également mais ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que tout doit être fait
parce que d'une certaine façon ça
contribue également au sentiment de
sécurité mais également à la bonne
économie de montréal merci monsieur
coderre à 45 secondes
non je suis promené dans vies lavez les
salles
le monde boisseau on dépense un budget
maintenant quand je t'ai 17 milliards de
dollars les gens ont l'impression qu'ils
ont peu plus de services alors on
reconnaît qu'un problème et puis on a
besoin un peu comme fait
morial centre-ville avec les sdc faut
évidemment quand on parle de propreté et
responsabilise et le nombre de celles
affaire de tous mais il ya un problème
alors on le cadre ce qui se passe
pendant quatre ans on voit que de plus
en plus de graffitis tout ça c'est ce
que c'est toujours un éternel
recommencement
mais il faut qu'on travaille en priorité
donc la question de la propreté ça c'est
essentiel dans les parcs dans les rues
dans les ruelles nous on a dit qu'au
niveau de la société de développement
pour le centre-ville en permettant un 10
millions et un autre 50 millions au
niveau des autres sd c'est donc sa ville
est reçue samedi les ressources mais il
faut que monsieur coderre vous allez
continuer en débat ouvert votre 45
secondes et termine et je veux qu'on
entende parce que ça il ya la propreté
ça sort davantage l'été au printemps
aussi quand la neige familiale hiver
l'hiver à montréal une relation parfois
difficile on va écouter une dame une
parle de trottoir est-ce qu'ils ont des
plans pour changer leur politique de
déneigement de déglaçage des trottoirs
est ce que ça va resté pareil ou est ce
que on va continuer à vivre la même
situation que depuis plusieurs années on
avait moi j'avais désespoir là pour
valérie plante est arrivée au pouvoir m
la mairesse et la mobilité mais si on
peut pas sortir de chez soi pour y aller
jusqu'au métro là on ne prendra pas le
métro
alors la même question qui lance le
débat est ce que on doit imaginer
d'autre façon de nettoyer de déglacer
les trottoirs en vendant planches dans
nos paroles ben écoute et oui faut
absolument innover tantôt je parlais des
déchets n'y est fait n'est pas précisé
mais se déchaînent hier qu'ils sont
équipés de gps ne serait ce que pour
s'assurer que toutes les routes sont
faits il ya vraiment un partage des
responsabilités entre l'arrondissement
et la ville puis des fois je vous dirais
que ça se passe bien d'autres fois c'est
plus difficile mais au final nous ce
qu'on veut c'est donner le plus d'outils
possible pour que les arrondissements
prennent les meilleures décisions
possibles par exemple il peut faire un
chargement de plus que dans un autre
arrondissement c'est le juge que c'est
pertinent alors on est vraiment dans
cette habileté dans cette flexibilité
qui vont nous permettre bien sûr de
déglacer également je vous cacherais pas
oui les changements climatique nous
affecte mais on doit
mais on est une ville d'hiver ça fait
depuis toujours qu'on gère la neige là
je vous dirais que le gros défi c'est de
maintenance avoir encore mieux gérer la
glace en période de gel et de dégel on
débat ouvert je suis content qu'on suit
la politique qu'on avait mis des vins
parle au début mais je comprends
mais c'est nous donnons changement peut
si on le fait c'est un essence ont
d'ailleurs une chroniqueuse ici
maintenant le problème est le suivant
c'est que on a un manque le bateau sur
l'accessibilité universelle quand on
parle de trottoirs n'ont pas le poids
juste de déneigement l'api de déglaçage
n'ont pas le même en plein été donc il
faut assurer qu'on ait cette sensibilité
là et qu'on met en priorité ceux des
glaçages la seconde question tu pas nous
a dit abbas et l'arrondissement on à
s'occuper puits d'eau il doit pas avoir
une mauvaise porte quand on a besoin de
services alors on va s'en occuper on va
travailler de cette façon là on a on va
mettre en place aussi une stratégie avec
les sd c'est que j'ai parlé tantôt avec
les partenaires pour qu'on puisse s'en
occuper et malheureusement quand on
parle d'accessibilité universelle
il pense ici ils se considèrent comme
des soins de seconde classe parce qu'ils
peuvent pas sortir ou quand ils sortent
de tellement tout bio même des années
passent on pense aussi à nos années il a
aucun problème majeur présent justement
parlons d'accessibilité universelle il
ya eu cette dame que j'ai rencontré à
rosemont bien me montrer là les trois
magasins pourraient pas très clair la
poussette là on est en bien tout 2022
est ce que c'est pour une obligation
commune pour une ville comme montréal de
d'accélérer et rendre les commerces
accessibles la réponse est oui oui je
pourrais je vous évitez tous les détails
du domaine bâti le c'est à dire à la
grandeur des trottoirs les façades les
patrimoines archipel des bâtiments
patrimoniaux
mais la réponse est oui et de la même
façon que notre administration a fait
avancer comme jamais la rénovation des
des entrées de métro des stations de
métro pour qu'elle soit toujours plus
accessible et 6,27 c'est l'ensemble du
réseau qui voit là est donc ça c'est
vraiment impressionnant donc pour nous
que ce soit de mettre des brigades qui
vont aider des personnes âgées ou des
personnes à mobilité réduite à des nerfs
j'ai leur entrée en premier parce qu'on
veut qu'il puisse être le plus mobile
possible d'essayer de prioriser
également tous les abords des hôpitaux
des métros pour encore une fois tenté le
plus rapidement possible de l'année
échappement du groupe et on veut le
faire on sait qu'on va le faire non on
l'interrogeait c'est à dire le problème
le promeneur et l'accessibilité
universelle
il ya des gens on peut avoir des bonnes
politiques puis gardé la gelée véhicules
mais aussi il ya un problème au niveau 2
au niveau des services et la livraison
des services donc on a besoin d'avoir
une voix qui va être capable d'assurer
qu'on ait cette sensibilité continuons
nos des candidates qui est qui ont qui
représente cela mais je pense qu'on a
besoin d'aller plus loin et c'est pour
ça qu'on a proposé un commissaire vous
une commissaire à l'accessibilité
universelle on a besoin d'avoir des voix
à l'intérieur pour assurer d'une plus
grande imputabilité pour la fonction
publique comme proposant comme il a eu
une commissaire mais ce que je peux vous
dire moi c'est encore une fois c'est du
très concret et quand on voit que les
gens qui se sont inscrits sur une liste
pour que leur entrée ou leur descente
d'escalier soit déblayé en priorité puis
que ça marche moi ça me fait extrêmement
plaisir c'est la bonne chose à faire est
de montréal on en parle beaucoup avec
raison ça a été un
régions oubliées
déserté pendant des années vous nous
proposez dans cette campagne électorale
de développer l'est en priorité qui est
le mieux placé pour y arriver débat
c'est nous c'est nous parce que nous
pendant notre mandat on a décidé que
c'est une priorité on ne s'est pas
réveillé en attendant c'est brest
important l'est de montréal donc je suis
très fier de dire que cette déclaration
panasonic madame rouleau et tous les
justes qui qui ont suivi au niveau de la
décontamination d'ailleurs parce que je
pense que monsieur coderre va aller là
dessus pour savoir quelle france cette
demande sont présentement étudiées pour
pouvoir décontaminer mais vous savez ce
dont je suis le plus fier c'est que par
rapport au réel de l'est nous on a
décidé qu'on n'attendait pas que le
train passe on de décider ce matin
d'injecter 500 millions de dollars pour
s'assurer que leur m2 laisse au project
est absolument essentiel dans lequel on
croit profondément assez pour y investir
5 millions $ pour qu'il soit exemplaire
et qu'ils rentrent à l'intérieur des
quartiers de façon harmonieuse pendant
trois ans les images que voici
me suis réveillé le mais j'étais 45 ans
est mort et allemand on est toujours
sensible à cette question de l'est de
montréal madame rouleau oui je le
connais bien le thé membres de mon
comité exécutif oui à des réalités de
décontamination parce que sur ça
mais une chose est certaine c'est que on
doit faire plus pour doit faire mieux
donc avec le statut de métropole que
nous nous sommes donné on a maintenant
des outils qui vont nous permettre de
travailler en conséquence d'un niveau de
l'habitation au niveau de la
diversification économique
on veut créer le silicon valley vers
police de montréal mais il faut
s'occuper faut s'occuper de la mobilité
donc on va tous travailler en ce sens
mais on a une équipe qui est non
seulement
mx qui connaît bien l'est de montréal
vous avez déclaré mme boivin roi qui va
faire un travail extraordinaire comme
mairesse pour mercier hochelaga
maisonneuve nous n'aurons pas de
problèmes sur les géo dans le faubourg
on va leur église c'est des petites
choses sader vous avez temmar qui vous
avez rien fait pour laisse donc à la
limite tous les deux là on a comme une
feuille de route on a comme commanderait
une feuille avec des éléments et
pourlèche rien qui a été fait quand vous
étiez maire ni pour moriana alors là
dessus pour l'efs de montréal je te dire
à ceux qui nous écoutent montre que
notre dévouement et l'intérêt qu'on a
pour l'ess il est réel on vient tout
juste de se réveiller gabella les
personnes qui se réveille le plan to
respect demandé à la communauté commun
on a fait rayonner montréal qu'on a
travaillé pour redonner on en a conclu
la renaissance de cette ville bien tant
sur le plan économique sur le plan
social sur le plan environnemental
également donc ce point de comparaison
10,4 et ceci non non on a travaillé
on a chacun et là je suis très fier de
mon bilan
pour le développement économique de
l'est a dit quatre ans pour le faire et
vous n'avez repos bouger moi j'ai bougé
mais moi j'ai pas la
différence vous avez été là pendant
quatre ans vous êtes on est en train de
préparer des affaires en train de
préparer puis ça s'en vient mais des
conditions gagnantes pour leur m2 laisse
alors que vous votre formation politique
a dit non on n'en veut pas de conduire
en conseillers en conseil municipal
monsieur badin ça m'aurait gens on
est d'accord
oui non sur le produit la froisse
secondes chacun leur m2 laisse même s'il
propose un petit souterrain au
centre-ville un petit donc vous allez
signer sur ce contrôleur vous êtes
d'accord qu'ils soient aérienne qu'on
soit clair second mais voilà nous on a
mis des conditions le rem 1.0 y avait
pas de conditions puis on doit vivre
avec des problèmes maintenant nous ce
qu'on dit c'est le tracé en souterrain
doit être évaluée dans mercier-est comme
s'est demandé mais également dans notre
terrain dans bergie absolument mais ça
c'est un processus le leadership c'est
de s'assurer qu'on fasse partie de la
décision donc les leaders
de ces partis annonce allait bien on va
voir ce cas d'accord au niveau sur m on
a besoin du hem parce que justement
comme godless de montréal on a été les
parents pauvres puis si on veut des
projets structurants on a besoin du
règne de l'instant ça va aider à les
pressions à l'économie et à la mobilité
l'environnement on écoute du site web
le sujet que vous priez que de voir
qu'est ce qui peut faire de plus pour
l'environnement pour conserver les
espaces verts
environnement avant tout mais surtout au
niveau du recyclage
chaque fois je vais prendre un café on
me donne un couvercle que je vais jeter
beaumont préoccupation c'est surtout
pour les changements climatiques et la
façon qu'on peut être réduire les
pollutions qu'on peut réduire les impôts
et missions
nous avons diffusé un sondage la semaine
dernière d'abord qui vous plaçait coude
à coude mais qui montrait que 60 % des
montréalais
est d'accord pour interdire les
véhicules à essence au centre ville donc
on a fait du chemin depuis est ce que
vous seriez prêt à les interdire plus
rapidement monsieur coderre car la
réponse est oui parce que quand montréal
est devenu membre sur notre leadership
de ses 40 on parlait déjà on passe d'une
météo grands brûlés où je croise en 2035
qui est pas de voiture essence qui est
des voitures électriques ces sept décès
dans cette foulée là qu'on a commencé
des bandes de recharge donc la réponse
est oui parce qu'on doit assurer de
cette transition là et de se donner des
paramètres il faut que nous soyons
carboneutre pour nous c'est 2045 qu'on
ait un budget carbone ici en ce sens
mais on a besoin nécessairement de
d'arrêter avec les voitures essence puis
je pense que on l'avait déjà commencé ça
se poursuit puis je pense que tout le
monde d'accord avec ce éventuellement
très bien madame plantes ce qu'on doit
accélérer
l'interdiction de tout véhicule à
essence au centre-ville la réponse est
oui et nous on l'a mis à l'intérieur
d'un plan climat qui a été fait par une
quantité d'experts dans le domaine
environnemental mais également d'une
nuit au niveau économique et sociale
mentionné et tout le monde était
d'accord pour dire que la relance verte
et inclusive c'est absolument nécessaire
moi j'ai envie de vous dire que cette
élection si elle est fondamentale parce
qu'il faut se positionner pour
aujourd'hui et pour demain il faut
décider quelle équipe est véritablement
est vraiment engagée et sérieuse prête à
faire des gestes courageux puis pas
toujours facile pour vraiment nous
amener vallar carboneutralité et dans ce
plan climat dont je vous parle on parle
de réduire le gaspillage alimentaire
vestimentaire c'est nous qui avons
essayé d'interdire le visage à placer
que une éco m'ont vu la dame avec sa
tasse de café et on a on ajoute mme
hilborn d'électrification parce que
c'est une des clés dont celui du
transport alors pour nous c'est
absolument essentiel et nous aurons ce
courage comme on le ferait pas mieux
maintenant ça revient souvent une
question
prenons le cas du golf d'anjou de vision
que vous avez pas la même vision tous
les fronts plusieurs sujets vos visions
se sont rapprochés le commentaire que je
referme la parenthèse pour le golf
d'anjou est ce qu'on protège où on
développe un protège débat on développe
mais on peut pas faire du développement
économique au détriment du développement
vert parce qu'à partir de maintenant il
n'y a pas de plan b à la planète mais on
a besoin de créer de la richesse pour la
redistribuer mais il faut s'assurer
qu'on combatte les inégalités alors dans
ce sens là non on n'y a pas personne qui
est plus environnementalistes que
l'autre on est tous contents la réponse
que vous venez de donner monsieur
coderre mais c'est que le développement
primer sur lesquels on verra si j'ai dit
voilà ouverte inclusive ça veut dire
qu'on fait une grille d'analysé sur les
projets et vous êtes prêt à développer
sur le dernier espace vert d'anjou pour
moi c'est un non sens parce que j'aime à
penser c'est que de nos jours il faut
acheter des terrains à forts coûts les
décontaminer qu'après sol et verdir
alors nous semble que la logique comme
on l'a fait que le nouveau pack de
l'ouest c'est de garder les espaces sous
le regard du fait qu à gauche avec le
dol bas on peut faire un pas absolument
y a pas tardé à remettre les pendules à
l'heure y a personne ici que ti que
c'est le développement économique au
détriment du développement vert on a
toujours travaillé en ce sens lopy on
n'a plus le choix de le faire de toute
façon mais un moment donné on peut faut
pas dire on va acheter des terrains puis
on n'a pas tout l'argent pour les payer
l'autre élément jugé mme soit vous êtes
audace alors voir dassieu zola pourquoi
qu'on n'a pas encore interdit de mazout
puis vous l'aviez dans les bâtiments
puis vous aviez dit que vous étiez pour
le faire est interdit et est pourquoi
alors comment on s'en va sur un élément
très précis vais écouter ça va me faire
plaisir de voler un jour plus à l'est de
ben ali alors étant donné que dans notre
plateforme nous sont des éléments très
concrets l'interdiction du mazout et
déjà prévu pour le niveau institutionnel
en premier et après ça au niveau
résidentiel et vous savez ce qu'on fait
c'est con parce que justement nous on
accompagne les citoyens ya plein de gens
dont des personnes aînées dans leurs
vieilles maisons qu'on est trop long
mais on est en train de mettre un
programme pour les accompagner parce que
moi je considère que les changements que
sont pas faciles à ces cons-là
différents g sur le mazout voulais c'est
que nous le dernier foyer pour le bois
là il faut la voiture bon on a dit on va
le faire puis on s'est donné une
séquence
au niveau du mazout vous irez vous étiez
pour dire que vous étiez pour
l'interdire dans les bâtiments pourquoi
qu'il prendrait deux maps crois que
c'est possible quand est ce que vous
l'avez fait parce qu'on travaille entre
autres avec la cmm c'est vous qui adorez
travail et qui dit souvent qu'il faut à
travailler avec la cmm moi je suis très
fier de dire que le programme moi je
fais pas de scoop et vous avez coupé
pour le lit pour avoir pillé beaucoup de
commerçants qui ont dit mais pourquoi
est-ce qu'on nous enlève notre moyen de
survivre moi ce que je fais je vois pas
mettre dans le trouble des familles ou
les accompagnements avoir fermé on peut
plus une fermette monsieur jean jeu on
est sur un aspect très très particulier
mais au final quand on regarde et
j'invite la population regarder la
plateforme environnementale ans dont
deux équipes et on voit clairement qu'il
va baisser
j invite les gens à comparer les deux
les deux plateformes et vous allez voir
que quand on parle en termes de concret
c'est au plus haut niveau dans un sens
moins on peut vouloir planter 500
milliards mais nous on veut s'assurer
que chaque rue ne soit pas sans âme et
ça ça va avoir un impact sur les îlots
de chaleur se tue sur l'acquis sable de
verdissement voire améliorer la qualité
de vie des gens mais je vous invite à
poser pour règlement dans un premier
temps puis après je vous invite à re et
être coupé des arbres comme soit au parc
jean-drapeau et maintenant dit que vous
allez en planter on sait pas combien on
ne sait pas où ça ce n'est pas concret
me sentais pas bien où vous allez
planter des arbres alors si les gens
dans toutes les revues allons parler
dans saint-michel et on peut se promener
on va l'aider à la mode est que c'est
concret faut avoir rappelé à avoir des
objectifs et dans votre plat il n'ya
rien vous devez vous allez voir les gens
m'ont compagne pendant la pandémie les
montréalais ont redécouvert leur parc
pour leur quartier les grands parcs
également j'ai eu la chance de faire un
petit reportage au parc angrignon il ya
quelques semaines un étranger un
américain ne retient qui arrive au parc
angrignon c'est une route il dit
j'aimerais prendre un petit café est
rien j'aimerais aller à la toilette ya
rien l'esa a été blessé et le sait les
deux administrations parce que plein de
chocolat ou
sous votre anisation aussi est-ce qu'on
a les moyens de faire des parcs qui sont
plus accueillants pour les montréalais
oui absolument en tout
respect on a commencé justement les
projets pilotes de toilettes publiques
dans ville marie on avait bon on avait
beau talent et pas toutes les auto
nettoyant ça c'est important oui on doit
re découvre on aurait tous croient nos
parcs au niveau de la pala avec la
pandémie oui c'est pour ça que je
parlais de propreté tantôt
toilettes à fait opaque à fond de nous
on a décidé de mettre un programme pour
aider les parcs locaux pour espère
réparer les vespasiennes et les parcs
les locaux de parc pour qu'on puisse
comme les chalets de parc voit là et ça
c'est un programme qui fonctionne très
bien si vous allez dans ville marie
mercier hochelaga maisonneuve on ne
dessine investir dans des équipements
qui servent aux familles pour aller
faire pipi ou juste pour mettre les
papas et des enfants ça à voir partout
j'en fais ça c'est en gras duels mais
nous on est des cdag concrètement thani
dans les cartes
spécifiques en ce sens là et c'est avec
les arrondissements donc un fonds de 120
millions qui touche notamment le
verdissement qui touche aussi les hervé
160 pollution à rafale ou sarah cette
émission le fil
sabia question rafale est ce que on doit
en faire plus pour protéger le français
à montréal madame plante le sait les
questions en rafale donc je vais vous
plaît oui et c'est pour ça qu'on a un
plan de protection de valorisation de la
langue française entre avec madame
louise harel pour l'application de la
nouvelle mouture de la loi 101 et on
vient d'engager la première commissaire
à la langue française de la ville de
montréal monsieur coderre le français
wim on a besoin d'un conseil de la
langue française tels que la motion
qu'on avait fait passer mais on doit
aussi travailler davantage sur la
francisation le statut de métropole avec
le bureau d'un test d'intégration des
nouveaux arrivants de montréal c'est une
façon de faire don tout en donnant des
services aux autres mais je pense qu'on
devrait miser aussi en termes
d'intégration sur la francisation et
vous entendez les deux qui évidemment
pas question de revenir avec une ville
bilingue morceaux mardi sur la même
longueur d'onde près histoire et
monuments historiques est ce qu'il ya
des monuments de jean nemec danon vous
aviez dit on va leur mettre monsieur
coderre parce que vous avez dit non
madame plante je sais pas où vous êtes
et moi si on est des cons ce qu'on doit
pas fait l'histoire les gens sont de
plus en sensible à ça que on peut pas
quand même biffé l'histoire ce combat
elle l'expliqué ou non mais moi s'est
excusé s'il faut pas politiser pied hors
de question moi j'étais pas très
confortable avec la position monsieur
kodak a décidé que ça changerait qu'elle
est un lieu pour la réconciliation sans
même avoir consulté les premières
nations elle m'avait alors moi je
travaille toujours en équilibre et c'est
pour ça qu'on est en train de mettre un
cas de reconnaissance qui va nous aider
à prendre des décisions mais qui ne
seront pas politique parce que c'est pas
propos nous c'est pas propre on ne se
connait roumois c'est à propos des gens
qui vivent avec des monuments qui
viennent les chercher
oui mais on va chez avec des experts ça
sera pas moins et se réveillera qui dit
qu on leur mettait mais quand ça veut
pas dire que il doit être sur le
piédestal c'est dans ce sens là je
parlais mais un quelqu'un qui ne connaît
pas son histoire et condamnés à la
répéter a dit elie oiseaux donc on a
besoin on ne peut pas déboulonner le
passé et quand on parlait de place de
réconciliation parce que moi j'étais un
de ceux qui a travaillé notamment sur
les pensionnats autochtones deuxièmement
sur la question du miel vous en souvenez
vous étiez correspondant parlementaire
l'époque à savoir donc on a on ad on a
un devoir de faire correctement et j'en
ai vous leur mettez vous à leur manière
je le remettrai au même niveau avec
l'acs explicative mais sur
la fin je répète plan de monsieur
coderre comment décririez vous votre
style de leadership monsieur kodak est
ce que vous avez quelle leçon vous avez
apprise de la fameuse formule 1 et
madame plantes quatre ans après quelles
leçons j'avais apprise en étant au
pouvoir comment vous décrivez très
rapidement c'est sûr que un moment donné
il faut faire une distinction
détermination et arrogance et c'est
clair que des fois on à métro mais moi
j'ai toujours eu un leadership assumé et
je suis fier d'eux en ce sens je dirais
jamais que c'est la faute des autres
volets se met pleinement
on doit avoir ce sens des métropoles qui
nous permet de joindre au point d'être
dans salles d'attentes on a un budget de
7 milliards de dollars maintenant on
représente 50 % de la population c'est
ce que on a un rôle à jouer au québec
comme au canada ce que j'ai envie de
vous dire c'est que je suis la première
mairesse de montréal mais surtout celle
qui a traversé la commune avec une
citoyens citoyennes et dans les choses
qui m'ont le plus touché deux parmi les
nombreux témoignages si on me parlait de
ma bienveillance de notre bienveillance
de notre administration pendant cette
période difficile d'être au rendez vous
de laisser personne derrière et ça pour
moi c'est important ce n'est pas à
propos de moi mais c'est le rôle que je
représente est mon leadership ce procès
il est inclusif et pas moi qui décide
tout moi je travaille avec l'élite tout
le monde rêvons un peu quel serait le
prochain grand projet de montréal je
connais mais je pense que on parle
beaucoup de rires premièrement on voit
se retrouver le premier projet c'est de
retrouver mon gars c'est de retrouver
cette magie c'est de redonner ce sens la
métropole où on peut avoir des quartiers
vibrant et c'est nécessaire tout en
ayant un grand projet il va voir il va
voir il faut qu'on refasse le
centre-ville l'est de montréal j'ai
parlé de recouvrement des 4 lei vous
réponde rapidement par c'est une
question concrète tu donnes réponses
concrètes alors ça sera 5 4e on est bien
on y met un milliard de dollars
sainte-catherine doit être c'est notre
première rue commerciale en amérique du
nord elle sera la plus belle si elle
convenir visite et déjà avec les
aménagements sur la rue mcgill college
le square libres et nous on veut l'ont
fait c'est de nos ports affaire
identique hélas une rue signature qui
t'apprennent se dessiner aux deux la
question se pose si vous perdez
restez-vous je connais j'ai envie de
rester ça c'est sûr mais je pense que de
plan a c'est c'est vraiment de gagner je
pense que montréal besoin d'un nouveau
leadership montréal cvc poche je prends
référendum sur ma personnalité c'est un
c'est les gens vont regarder ce que
l'administration actuelle au fait dans
les quatre ans et on a une alternative à
leur proposer madame plan en 2017 moi
j'avais dit oui monsieur coderre s'était
moqué de la question vous avez décidé de
quitter le bateau alors moi je considère
que si la population veut me donner le
rôle de chef de l'opposition rôle que
j'ai déjà occupés qui est important pour
la démocratie
et dans ce cas ce moment là je pense
qu'il faut pouvoir accepter ce verdict
et aller de l'avant mais bien sûr
j'invite tous les montréalais à voter
pour projet montréal très bien pourquoi
les montréalais devrait aller voir et je
vous donne 10 secondes chacun les gens
devraient aller voter parce que c'est
important pour la démocratie et moi
j'aurais aimé que les gens de 70 ans et
plus et plus voter aussi par votre
postale à cause de la pandémie mais
c'est une question de respect de
l'institution 10,55 jeu l'éditeur tôt
c'est une élection qui est importante
pour aujourd'hui et pour demain et quand
les questions 35 aux logiques on le doit
à nos enfants nos petits enfants aller
voter allons voter merci beaucoup
vraiment là vous avez été exemplaire ce
soit un débat intelligent merci mesdames
et messieurs d'avoir été là allez voter
samedi dimanche prochain on sera bien on
se revoit le 7 novembre
l'élection
[Musique]